Telltale Games is known for adapting
properties like The Walking Dead game of
thrones and borderlands into their
choose your own adventure style of
gameplay and we've just gotten a tease
for what they're tackling next I'm Tony
and this is your robotic gamespot news
update it looks like telltale has its
sights set on USA Network's mr. robot
for its next game adaptation the team's
Twitter and Facebook page have released
videos promoting a messaging app from a
corp the evil organization from the show
whether this is a smaller tie-in or
another full fledged episodic series is
unclear but the videos mention an august
seventeenth release date for the app so
we shouldn't have to wait too long to
find out Telltale's most recent episodic
series is batman which just premiered
this month we scored the first episode
an 8 out of 10 so we definitely have
some confidence in what telltale does
stick with us as we wait to see what the
studio does next and for all the most
important video game news you're already
in the right place